ci avrei scommesso tempo fa che la
prossima volta che avrai sentito questa
canzone sarei stato in paradiso
e invece no siamo ancora qua è là a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
sono fa vj oggi siamo
e difficile da dire perché siamo
ritornati su un gioco che non pensavo di
aprire mai più però siccome ho fatto
octo dead mi sono trovati filse e molti
di voi non sanno che cos'è questa cosa e
io sono innamorato di questo gioco sia a
turbo liz mount che un gioco che facevo
sempre ai tempi di tipo octo del tipo
secoli fa non ero ancora nato quando lo
facevo
siccome ragazzi in questo gioco c'è il
personaggio principale che si schianta
per terra nei tre secondi è possibile
anche selezionare la faccia del
personaggio in questione quindi io direi
che questo sezionale pietro giustamente
possiamo partire solo per vedere allora
hanno aggiunto anche un botto di roba
che non ho mai giocato direi di fare
delle cose abbastanza cioè non partiamo
dall'inizio ma facciamo tipo the space
program che mi la madonna come faccio a
stare sta roba più che sarà un passo un
curioso di vedere eccolo o perfetto non
avrei saputo immaginarlo meglio di così
va bene avremo un pietro che ci fissa
per tutto il video che è un po
inquietante se ci fate caso però non
possiamo aggiungere le robe facciamo la
b gran parte nov hanno aggiunto è
fighissimo
va beh direi che possiamo provare così
alla presunzione micro più cioè ragazzi
sto gioco non ci gioco da una vita è una
figata incredibile sera è in penso che
il camion non si è in grado di fare
questa cosa in tutta onestà però da
posto zio dai ragazzi allora facciamo
una roba più fisici come ce n'erano un
miliardo di livelli come lo ricordo
scaramanga che è fidata doveva fare al
tecnico una macchina ci sono anche
ovviamente un sacco di macchine io direi
di provare questa roba non c'erano tutti
un divano è che questa è una scena che
non vorrei mai vedere nella mia vita
la prima vedere se il divano con le
ruote riesce ad arrivare dall'altra
parte 3 2 1 a con le cose anche
è vero è vero significato di cambiare le
forze
mio dio questo non è tanto da youtube
però facciamo finta di niente
pietro di rimanere attaccato al divano è
perché sennò non arrivi dall altra parte
della corsia quindi rimane fermo è un
salto di successo dovrai perfetta devo
decisamente attaccare delle ruote al mio
divano ragazzi suo nome abbiamo solo che
cose belle da scoprire
ovviamente le sere seriamente ad
arrivare dall'altra parte con magari una
macchina decente tipo questo eva è la
madonna prova ci sono per curiosità
voglio della quanto vasta roba lì è
proprio quello che mi aspettavo però
governo non è tanto questo è che pensavo
volasse non penso che volli perché
proviamo la più veloce che esista credo
sia questa qua le altre posizioni
conosci scusami a ok chiaro non avevo
altri goodbye così burqa ma che sto
facendo o chiocchio pietro occhio
chiariva davvero male
non ti sei fatto malissimo dai trader e
altre posizioni eccoli va bene a queste
tre ok
comunque sia è velocissima negato con la
madonnina
[Applauso]
ce l'ho fatta pietro no ma la macchina
si quale l'importante credono ma rimane
attaccato pietro se no non rimane
attaccato quanto pare non lo sono più
bravo di quanto mi ricordassi
complimenti famiglia mister ego cosa sto
vedendo sposa vedo o mio dio
non credo nonché
[Musica]
va bene adesso cosa si cambiare i
personaggi visto stallworth madron
tutto ciò che nella vita non volevo
vedere questo ha quindi in base al
personaggio cambia anche la cosa avere
direi che no no no ti sei salvato per un
niente
va bè ragazzi della primavera un'altra
di macchina e poiché abbiamo al tipo
questo street slicer però cambia
personaggio zio facciamo io non pensavo
di poter vedere questa scena nella mia
vita proviamoci
ben lo vedo carico lo vedo pronto
secondo me ce la fa non diffidate qua
dal fatto che tu sia accaduto è già un
traguardo incredibile però belle boccia
è amico mio
cambiamo il cono che c'era una mappa
bellissima dove deve schivare le auto
sull'autostrada praticamente mi ricordo
quale però immagino sia come freeway
ecco non era questo ma va bene uguale
de weld questa mi sembra la macchina
abbastanza buona se cambiamo magari
persona già pietro non riesco a vederlo
così
mazza o questa macchia l'hack è male lo
schifo già è vero che c'è la collisione
giustamente che è successo la prova
mandarlo un pelo piano ragazzi perché
voglio vedere cosa succede se si
schianta contro le altre macchine e per
la scienza pietra per la scienza secondo
me non l'ha presa bene però book è
rimasto schiacciato un lauto porca vacca
e vabbè mi sa che si è fatto malissimo
pietro però ok of jobs i semi donare 5
dollari su paypal nel prossimo episodio
metto la faccia del vostro peggior
nemico guarda voglio solo vedere ma per
curiosità sempre per la scienza schifo
l'autobus è andata veramente bene
stavolta è passato sotto tutto madama
come che fisica amico mio lo so che sei
esperto in queste cose ma a darsi un
contegno per cortesia va bene ragazzi
sono soddisfatto della mia vita
per me questi video potrebbero non
finire mai però vabbè vabbè la madonna
prova a cino giusto per curiosità
secondo me arriva dall'altra parte c'è
dubbio
esatto pietro incastrato in autostrada
questa roba ancora credo che sia
successo qualcosa non so se è colpa mia
però famiglia per chi se lo ricordava
posso posizionare le robe posso mettere
una rampa che non c'era prima
dovremo farla tutta giusta tipo non sono
sicuro che io riesca a farlo e pro ci
provo lo stesso
provaci zio proci non così così esatto
mi sa che non è andata proprio benissimo
ma neanche per gli altri però ok un pelo
più piano
[Musica]
è andato più veloce adesso che prima
come possibile andiamo avanti ragazzi lo
più the loop o mio dio era bellissimo
the loop grave ma comunque la morte in
penna sera al massimo non so quanto
convenga
[Musica]
mi sono cagato addosso c'era un muro
invisibile
poi vabbè dritto zio dritto
dritto nostri no non è il proprio in
mente il concetto di dritto vita devo
riuscire a fare il giro della morte
legate una questione proprio mia di
orgoglio personale ce la fai ad andare
dritto questa moto maledizione ma niente
con la moto non va dritto per sicurezza
proviamoci
con questa perché vi piace veramente con
l'altro impossibile prova vedere non ti
prometto nulla
perché perché spiegami perchè
maledizione la vita vai
eccovi positivo
[Musica]
o o a c'era un muro lì non avevo visto
va bene siamo riusciti a fare quello che
volevo fare dall'inizio passo ad un
punteggio ragazzi il look del lupo è
riuscito proprio vedere se riesco a fare
qualcosa tipo ma così no seriamente
ok perfetto sono proprio curioso di
vedere come lo fa il suo giro della
morte amico mio curiosissimo è il caro
noto lo ha fatto e lì se tu rimanessi
attaccato li mortacci tua le avremo
forte a quest'ora ci pensavo molto
peggio eccolo eccolo eccolo eccolo
tensione e signori siamo riusciti a
farlo incredibile quel che era nato è
tanta roba
non ci avrei dato un euro vale ragazzi
se hai claver let's golf
mammamia questo conterà difficile regalo
per evitare quel carro armato sempre
cosa ci esce secondo me demolisco tutti
era difficilissimo arrivare alla fine è
a posto a zio mi sa di no
occhio alle macchine che vanno del carro
armato è preso malissimo sto spingendo
tutti
dov'è il lo skate board colore ecco
questo era veramente figo
provaci proci prodi sdraiato c'è e dott
ok questo era quello che volevo c'è una
macchina c'è una macchina c'è una
macchina
[Musica]
grazie se non avessi fatto tu l'avrei
fatto io puoi evitare l'unica macchina
che passa almeno nella prima corsia
nelle altre colori vuole solo quella c'è
ok bravo con la barca vacca di
riprovarci anche stavolta in teoria
dovrei riuscire a farcela
cioè niente per finire sul livello dorin
passare tutte le macchine ma impossibile
[Musica]
occhio porca vacca per sono arrivato
sono arrivato senza la testa ma sono e
dove la testa per fermi che devo capi
dov'è finita a destra e ancora era
ancora nella macchina dove sta andando
dio mio
dove vai pietro dove era finita la testa
come è finita qua i ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto cosa mi piace
anche vari social condotto dalla
descrizione se ci si chiede se non ci
diamo alla prossima vita da ragazzi
[Musica]